it's it's rooted in like trauma like
just fear it bothers me so much like for
example um cometier coffee um i they
sent me some for free it's so good but
it's a dollar fifty per cup
and compare that to like you being
coffee i'm like a dollar fifty sometimes
i don't even drink the whole thing
and so like i've been really struggling
with like
is that worth it is this worth it
[Music]
can i tell you something uh interesting
i saw so
um
the one the 0.01 rule so nathan barry
came on the pod
and
he was cool so he's the the founder of
convertkit he came on he was telling us
about some blog posts that either he's
written or the other different that he
liked so i went back and i read one of
them
and i saw this thing called the 0.01
percent rule have you seen this no okay
so
he's pretty amazing i'm gonna pull up
this uh where's the blog 0.1
rule wealth let me see if i can pull it
up here
um
okay i'm not gonna be able to find it
real quick here but i'll put the link in
ben if you can find it or search nathan
barry wealth ladder 0.01
so basically
the way the guys think he's like he's
like you know
um
he's like he talks about price
sensitivity he's sort of like you know
as you get more rich you um
you know the way you think about money
should change right this is like when i
came to your house and you had like cvs
receipts in the glove compartment
because you're like saving them for like
the three dollar thing you're like hell
yeah
and i was like dude you just sold your
company for like many many millions of
dollars uh what are you doing with these
cvs receipts you're like i just like to
do it it's a habit
and so this guy talks about like
the richer you get um
you should sort of he's like he's like
this works for when you sell something
to somebody or yourself as you get to
that level basically below 0.01 percent
of your net worth so that's you take
your net worth you multiply by 0.000
whatever you know one so it's like uh
0.01 of your net worth so let's say
you're worth um let's do 100 million so
100 million what is it times what use
five billion right they'll use a little
bit more of a approachable number here
so
um
so that would be five hundred dollars
for if you have five million dollars a
net worth five hundred dollars at the
threshold
below which you don't really feel it you
don't really care or feel it you can
become a little bit price insensitive
below that point so that might be like
you know
opting for the you know the nicer hotel
or like you just really don't give a
[__] you can just ball out at a
restaurant you really don't care uh and
so he draws this little curve and he's
like at um at the first level of wealth
it's like
he calls it like level zero level one of
wealth where it's like you know your
0.01 is like a hundred dollars or less
than a hundred dollars at that point a
million dollars
yeah a million dollars would be a
hundred bucks yeah so he's like you know
at that point like you know if you're at
the grocery store and something costs an
extra dollar like you care you don't
want to buy the eggs that cost 1.99 more
you care he's like then the next level
the next jump up is you're like well i
don't care at like you know it's the way
he draws the chart it's like what are
restaurant prices then the next one's
like what are vacation prices like you
don't even really care about how much
your vacations cost the next one is like
you you know you could fly first class
and then the final one is like you know
or the next one's like you can buy a
crazy house you know you don't really
get you're not really feeling uh house
prices as much and then the final one is
like you know what are prices anyways
like you know this is when you're worth
over 100 million dollars like at that
point most things don't cost anything to
you and um you're pretty insensitive to
the cost of it so i'm sort of
summarizing the idea the exact you know
you can quibble about
what you should or shouldn't care about
but i thought it was kind of an
interesting number and the reason i
bring it up is
very few people that i know
are like properly price sensitive
so there's a lot of people i know like
my dad who no matter how wealthy they've
got like these sort of like the trauma
of not having money is so deeply
ingrained in his body
that like
you know
starbucks he's just like he's like
pissed off when they charge even if he
buys the coffee it like he's angry at
the price he's like oh my god 4.99 like
i could make this for so much less and
they're like sir you're welcome to do
that and he's like oh like what's going
on and you know he's anchored to prices
from like the 80s when like you know
that's where like he thought movie
tickets should cost x and also you know
it just like hurts him to spend more
than some amount regardless of what's in
his bank account and so he's kind of on
one side of the spectrum too cheap and
then there's another side spectrum which
we're more where i am where it's like
dude you should really kind of pay
attention to this you're kind of
spending like pretty crazy and uh you
know completely price insensitive is on
the other side and then there's like
whatever the sweet spot is and then
school they don't really teach you how
to
how to like gauge that or what what
those kind of like
what even should be a good number for
this what should i spend on things so
you you don't get nervous like i i freak
out a little because as an entrepreneur
like some years i just like knock it out
the park and make so much money other
years i make nothing
uh i mean
hopefully i don't think nothing will
ever happen again but like there's times
you don't get nervous about running out
no actually like two months ago i was
like oh my god i have like no cash left
no cash on hand left i was i was
investing in everything i saw i was
putting money into startups and to
crypto into stuff i was then i was
spending a bunch like my payroll
expanded and i was like oh my god i have
like so little cash
i thought that way too it was under
i had 60 grand in cash and i was like i
feel low yeah i think it was like 38 000
was in my like whatever wells fargo
checking account i was like where'd all
the money go this was like
and i was like oh yeah i guess and i
looked at the like out outgoing thing
and it was like it's not that my
spending had gone up i was really just
investing a lot of money but i was like
wow i should uh i need to manage cash
for most of the time for me it's like i
need to send my invoices for like things
you know like i was like all right i'm
gonna teach a course and i'm gonna
invoice you know for the podcast and i'm
gonna like do the things that bring in
like cash today versus most of the
things i invest my money into are like
long-term illiquid things or my own
businesses right like uh maybe i should
take a withdrawal out of my business and
like put money in my bank account and so
so you know it was just like a reminder
of that
but no i don't really get too worried
about that um
and maybe you know again i think i'm too
far on the dial of like willing to spend
on whatever
ramit safety this is pretty much what
his entire
uh not course but his entire image and
content is about which is like
he's got this podcast where two people
couples argue like we have
we're worth three million dollars and he
got into a fight with me because i spent
eighty dollars on this silly thing
and
ramit's all about that it's i have i'm
more like your father than i am like you
like
and i think it's just rooted it's it's
rooted in like trauma like just fear uh
i've got the same thing we're just like
it's like it bothers me so much like for
example um cometeer coffee um i they
sent me some for free it's so good but
it's a dollar fifty per cup
and compare that to like you being
coffee i'm like a dollar fifty sometimes
i don't even drink the whole thing
and so like i've been really struggling
with like
is that worth it is this worth it or
the backsplash on my sink in my kitchen
we need to replace it and it's eight
hundred dollars and i've been fretting
over it for over a year now i'm like ugh
eight hundred dollars to replace that i
can't so
even though it will add value to the
home and also make me happier i
understand why your dad thinks that way
it's really it's real i think it's
challenging when you're it's like
it's like
you know it's proper trauma i think of
like
you felt one way for years and now you
suddenly like things are different yeah
maybe we actually need money therapy
uh money therapy specifically i think
that's actually a good idea here so
therapy is this broad thing that has
like a bunch of associations with it and
mostly it's like stigmas and blah blah
blah i think somebody needs to spin off
and remember it sounds like he's kind of
doing this which is just a great idea
financial therapy
um and it's like yeah have a money coach
or you know you probably need to
switching therapy to coach is the hack
to like
oh i'm focusing on performance and not
like uh you know
fixing a pr broken part of me uh but
in reality it's that i tried finding
people like this and when i met them i
was like look
we're just getting knowledgeable not a
financial advisor different thing no i
know
when i go i would go to therapy for a
lot and i would and i would go when i
whenever i was trying out a new
therapist i'd be like so i'm not going
to like i'm not trying to sound like a
douche or big-headed but like
i'm a high achiever like i want to like
conquer the world and like do cool [__]
and so i don't want to talk like this is
this is the the place that i'm coming
from like i'm high octane baby can can
we can we make this happen do you have
the tools necessary or no or do you like
specialized just in like
you know like traditional way what were
you really trying to tell her you were
trying to tell her that my problems are
not like i'm not broken i'm trying to
like just achieve a higher level of
success or were you trying to tell me
what i'm going to have
a player therapist is that what you were
trying to ask her what were you trying
to ask him no the blunt way to explain
it is i've got rich i'm i'm complaining
about some rich people problems okay and
like i'm just like mostly just insecure
about certain things and i want to like
use that to like conquer the world i'm
not very good on twitter
yeah and like i'm gonna complain about
stuff that sounds super weak because
like on outside like everything's going
great but i need you to like empathize
that like i'm trying to like go places
and i don't need you to tell me that
like well you made a million dollars
that last year isn't that good enough
like no dog that's not like i need you
to understand like what like what's at
stake here you know what i mean
i said what is at stake here
that's like you're better i'm gonna be
i'm gonna be i'm gonna be your money
therapist but you know what i mean like
it's so like i would be people and i'm
like oh you've only worked with like a
certain type of person you have like i
don't think you unders i don't think
you'll be able to help me
yeah yeah exactly i know what you mean
it's the reason tony robbins gets paid a
million dollars plus per client because
it's like his clients are serena
williams and ray dalio and you know or
whoever he's crazy
yeah and he himself is successful and
his other clients are
you know
objectively very successful but
everybody
um you know can improve the you know the
little voice in their head
[Music]
you